what we thought was a done deal
congressional testimony next week by
former Special Counsel Robert Muller may
not be tonight we're learning there is
some wiggle room at least in the eyes of
the nation's top law enforcement
official chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge is here
to explain with congressional testimony
looming sources tell FOX News former
Special Counsel Robert Muller remains a
reluctant witness and a number of
options are under consideration
traveling in South Carolina Attorney
General William Barr seemed to offer an
exit ramp if Bob decides that he doesn't
want to be subject to that and the
Department of Justice would certainly
back him Muller is scheduled to publicly
testify next Wednesday before the
democratic-led House Judiciary and
intelligence committees his nearly five
hundred page report found no criminal
conspiracy between the Trump campaign in
Russia but did not quote exonerate the
President on obstruction of justice Barr
frowned on House Democrats for
compelling molars testimony I was
disappointed to see him subpoenaed
because I don't think that serves an
important purpose dragon-bot Muller up
if he in fact is going to stick to the
report it seems to me the only reason
for doing that is to create some kind of
public spectacle in May Muller gave his
only public statement on the Russia
report findings and he did not take
reporter questions the report is my
testimony I would not provide
information beyond that which is already
public in any appearance before Congress
in a separate development sources tell
Fox News the former British spy
Christopher Steele behind the
controversial Trump dossier was so
concerned that he could get quote thrown
under the bus in a forthcoming Inspector
General report that he agreed to
cooperate Reuters broke new details this
morning that Steele was interviewed in
the UK in June by three lawyers working
for Inspector General Michael Horowitz
who is investigating alleged
surveillance abuse targeting the Trump
campaign the I G's office is not
commenting on the status of their work
brett following kevin thanks